tu me fais plaisir cei ne vais tout de
vidéos et non voilà ça je me souviens
c'est ma période amoureux de la nature
[Musique]
je sais je sais je sais pourquoi vous
rigolez c'est parce que j'ai des grands
cheveux c'est ça oui c'est ma [ __ ]
qu'elle pousse pierre dit tu crois que
si j'habite bien sûr sinon j'aurais mis
un truc plus gros bond cette vidéo
projetée au stade de france dans deux
écrans de 340 m² chacun de 34 tonnes
c'est simple babbitt faisait un médecin
oui bah tu l'aurais sur le nez ça te
fait une belle paire de lunettes
alors tout le monde se dit [ __ ] mais
ce mec que tu as fait le stade de france
52 mille personnes ces dix mais qui sera
heureux jusqu'à la fin de ses jours
c'est terminé il a tout fait toi et il
sera heureux tout le temps avec moi je
vous dis non
[Rires]
même après ces textes war merveilleux il
ya toujours des trucs qui me gonfle et
là qu'elle n'est pas content je ne sais
pas trop tard vous voyez que je suis
content ta gueule
et toujours des trucs qui me gonfle par
exemple j'en ai toute une série bien sûr
je vous pose la question au quotidien tu
nous gonfles par exemple est-ce qu'on en
parle
oui du rouleau de scotch ou pas on en
ouais c'est le rouleau de scotch qui
fait 10 mètres sur la repérer d'un
magasin ses marques et sud dit m toi tu
veux bien le croire et les prochaines
dif et sûrement 10 mètres est en train à
maison tu déballe le bbl le paquet tu
t'aperçois que c'est vrai qu'il n'est
pas cher mais lui il a pas de langue est
démarrée en octobre tu le pense mais
dans la lumière comme ça tu fais un tour
d'un côté c'est un tour de l'autre tu
dis bon c'est bon ça te dit attends je
vais passer l'ongle je vais la voir je
vais passer longue tu passes un tour
deux tours et tire toi le couteau à pain
qui est là avec l'état n'y tient pas
bien ta gueule toi et la tuque ou 25
couche d'un coup tu les regardes jeudi
que le dta petite gueule de merde là tu
le prends tu fais un tour est arrivé au
bout dit il répète été obligés de
rechercher le bout et les crises mais
qui ont trois côtés si je dois voter me
fait huer d'accord que elles sont trois
côtés la preuve tu essayes de la rentrée
comme ça
tu sais comme ça tu rester comme ça tu
vois bien qu'ils ont trois côtés c'est
pour nous faire chier et la poubelle de
salle de bain on n'a pas parlé de ça un
mois qui passe ma vie dans les hauteurs
comme ne te ça tue la repérer à vous y
êtes allez certainement peut-être là bas
à la maison moins souvent que moi mais
quand même vous la connaissez la petite
poubelle de salle de bains qu'on te mets
à l'hôtel petite poubelle blanche en
plastique très léger avec la grosse
[ __ ] noir tu as pu taper
j'avais la tête ouvre pas nouvelle toute
la poubelle vient claquer sur ton tibia
mais s'ouvre pas alors pourquoi il
jamais une [ __ ]
si on obligé de se baisser pour leur est
allé à lons supermarché hayon fruits et
légumes là j'aimerais bien savoir c'est
qui
c'est qu'est le pervers qu'inventer les
sacs qui s'ouvre pas 1 sat afrique est
belle courgettes pour l'apurer des bébés
qu'elle les a seulement tu dis faut que
je prenne un sac
tiens déchets et là c'est parti ça doit
pas être le bon côté autant d annoncer
le fond là toi entre temps les congés
kate ont peint
ouais c'est vrai ouais ça je garantis un
truc si jamais je le chope ce mec-là
d'ailleurs à mon avis vous allez me dire
ce que vous en pensez
à mon avis ça doit être le même gars qui
s'amusent à glisser dépistage fermés
dans les petits sachets un césar tu m'as
tu peux pas les louper c'est les quatre
dernières toi tu les as payé tu veux
nous faire tu te ruine les ongles le
sucre et puis il ya un moment tu perd
patience
temps chaud punk il y tient il ya bien
ta gueule toi écrabouille dans ta bouche
elle est mort ce côté qui défense la
langue le palais met un aria personnes
auxquelles est mauvais et pour finir je
vous dirais comme vous l'avez
certainement constaté depuis quelques
temps j'ai un petit peu levé le pied sur
la muscu
oui tu peux te fous de ma gueule
eric guimbeau et francis e61 un petit
bout d'une équipe
bon alors attention c'est pas la salle
de muscu qui m'exaspère un pas du tout
celle du véhicule en fait c'est génial
hein
eh bien oui monsieur celle des risques
une petite tape à la place chez toi un
tas d x 2000 mais carré de machine peut
travailler muscle après muscle assez
épatant seulement après c'est ça qui me
dérange le plus il ya des douches
communes
c'est là que ça se complique
parce que là si tu veux que tu vois un
mec sortir de ce dans ce genre de douche
il sort très vite opinion que cela mais
ces petites serviettes que ça peut faire
mal aux yeux et c'est vrai on est
honnête il a dit ni bonjour ni au revoir
à personne c'est pas qu'il ait pas poli
c'est qu'il est une petite [ __ ] situer
cet endroit là c'est la hiérarchie de la
dictature maroc en général le plus poli
dans toute la bande
comme par hasard c'est le mec qui est le
plus sévèrement membres est alors lui
litres
il a un bras d'enfants avec une tête de
chat au bout on se demande tous il a
attrapé ça alors lui est très politique
et celui tout le monde a ses bons jours
et bonjour bonjour c'est en fait son
bonjour à ce mec-là je vous dire ce que
c'est son bonjour avec un socle est ce
que si on fait ça c'est bonjour tu as vu
et où je t'ai vu bonjour tu as eue
t'as pas vu huawei seuil et ouais t'as
vu jobs liga merci merci et moi qui te
regardent ces mots d'ordre à bercy